I call this the Jay Leno starter kit so
he says basically hey man you know if
you like cars you can invest in them and
when you sell them if you sell them
you'll make money on them but you get to
enjoy your investment it's like Bitcoin
you can drive
hello my name is Gabriel Iglesias that's
Iglesias if you have an accent or
Iglesias if you don't we are here at my
compound in beautiful Long Beach
California this is basically a glorified
man cave I call it a one bedroom 80 car
garage it's a big glorified
multi-purpose room my first car was a
1968 Volkswagen bus that my brother
helped to get me uh probably cost about
400 bucks at the time I want to say it
was like 16 17. I had the car for a
couple years I pushed it I drove it I
ran out of gas in it I mean none of the
gauges worked I knew how fast I was
going if I was next to another car and I
could see their speedometer I'd ask the
guy to like how fast were you going okay
cool now I know I can go 30. it was my
first car and you always fall in love
with your first car and so uh years
later when I was I was hanging out with
Jay Leno Jay's guys this car his car
guys he's got guys he knows people they
said hey if you're ever looking for a
car in particular let us know we'll see
what we can do for you they called me
the next day and they had a bus and I
was like Wow and then they said if you
want anything else let me know and I
said well if you come across something
let me know and they called me the next
day and so basically we were playing
this game back and forth for about a
year and it took a little under a year
to collect all these buses
all right this is the one that started
it all this is the 1968 Volkswagen bay
window bus my original bus looked like
this in my dreams it was actually gray
and white but did not look like this
this is the car that I wanted to get
back it's very different and the design
inside it's a lot more a lot more fluffy
friendly if you will my first car was a
1968 bay window which is different than
these these are all split windows and
mine has the full windshield the seats
are back just a little bit more and it
handles a little bit better than the
let's say the split window that's a 1956
next to a 1968 so clearly you could see
the evolution there
this is the Ironman bus the color scheme
on it is very different than buses that
are out there it's very very custom if
Iron Man got converted into a Volkswagen
bus that's what it would look like a
little homage to uh Mr Tony Stark as you
can tell the height difference uh this
is the standard height right here and
then this is the lowered you know people
say oh why'd you mess it up you lowered
it it looks cool and I got a couple
others that are the right height so hit
all you want buses back in the day
didn't exactly have this much Chrome on
them I kind of went a little Chrome
happy so anywhere I could put Chrome
there's Chrome that's Mexican in me but
anyway the wheels are Porsche Alloys
back in the day there was no options for
Volkswagens you you pretty much had to
just go with Porsche Parts if you had
Porsche Alloys on your car you were
doing something right that was your like
ooh but now there's like a million
different kinds of Wheels you could put
in your car but back in the day four
shallow is the only way to go and yes
the Porsche logo is on there because
yeah you got the bay window back in the
day because that's what you could afford
the split windows are the price
difference is huge so for example a 1967
in this condition probably at one of
those auctions they'll go from anywhere
from 100 to 150 000 whereas a bay window
one year later you can get for about 25k
they made more more cartoons and more
things with that the bay window look
versus the split window but these are
unmistakable there's nothing that looks
like them
all right behind me is a 1967 camper it
originally started off white and we
decided to kind of have some fun with it
these are like very much in the vein of
the Bentley colors we wanted to have
something to give it a little bit more
class a little more style make it you
know a little nicer it was just plain
white I bought it from a guy in Germany
who bought it from a guy in California
so this bus started off in California
went to Germany and then came back to
California
this is a straight up camper This was
meant for outings and don't get me wrong
I'm sure you could live in the other
ones too but this one actually has a bed
in the back it's got you know wood
cabinets the original one had a little
baby stove in it and a little cooler I
had it taken out because I ain't gonna
make no grilled cheese in there I got a
form and Grill it's got curtains and
it's it's actually really really
comfortable I wanted to make sure that
if I if I redid the camper that it had
enough power to go up if I ever wanted
to take it to Big Bear so it's ready to
go
how does it make me feel to drive a
Volkswagen bus well first of all you're
up really high these were out before
SUVs anytime you get an SUV you always
feel above and you can see down on
everybody and kind of the same thing you
get one of these you're cruising you
have no blind spots in these things so
you can see everything it's all coming
at you right there there's no hood so
unfortunately if you hit something you
have about two inches of metal between
you and whatever you hit the question
was asked by Jay Leno why so many of the
same car he goes it's boring you're
buying the same car it's the same car
same car same car thing and I'm like Jay
I go when people see these now now it's
kind of like a brand association thing
they're always sending me pictures of
buses and hey look at this one my
cousin's selling one and so they know me
now as the bus guy it's really cool that
I've Associated myself with such an
iconic thing
I am standing here right in front of
this beautiful
1959 23 window bus I got this bus about
three years ago the guy who does all my
Restorations he showed up here one day
in this car and uh he left walking
because I bought it off of him that day
yeah it was already pimped out it was
good to go and I think he did that on
purpose pretty sure he did that on
purpose the biggest difference between
this 1959 and this one next to me is the
1967. they look very similar but uh as
you could tell the turn signal lights
one is flat looks like an egg the other
one kind of has like a little nipple I
don't know if I could say nipple on GQ
but yeah I don't know who's nipple but
somebody's nipple that's what it looks
like so uh most of my buses have uh roof
racks and that's that's an accessory
it's an option I just thought it looked
cool you know I don't really put stuff
up there but it is you can it's earrings
pimped out earrings they're really
pretty not not so much practical but
pretty
the trucks were made for you know just
like now someone goes out and buys an
F-150 they got to work they got things
to do they did not look like that back
in the day uh I had Chrome put all over
them they probably did not have Chrome
back in the day when they were being
used for work there's a lot of uh
compartments in there so you know you
stick your tools it's they're working
trucks when I got them uh they were they
were they were being used for work so I
had to clean them up a lot
this truck right here it's a single cab
and uh when I first got it I got catfish
this is why I tell people you got to go
see the cars for yourselves make sure
you take someone with you so you can get
a second pair of eyes if you're going to
invest a lot of money into one of these
I bought this thing it was a mess it was
crooked it was it was it was more
crooked than my last account this this
thing was just bent it was all messed up
like the whole body was tweaked out and
then they they used a lot of filters in
the photos and I'm like this is a great
deal and then the guy goes you know you
don't got to do much to it okay okay and
once the check cleared yeah apparently I
did I had to basically put you know
three times the amount into that truck
to straighten the body and then paint it
and then make it look the way that it
does the beauty of it is that it
actually runs really well now it handles
great it doesn't just look pretty
it is pretty this rack right here it
it actually was uh covered up it looks
kind of like a tent reminds me of those
old school uh movies where they show the
guys in Vietnam and everybody's in the
back and it's just covered up I had it
taken off because it wasn't it didn't
look pretty so I I you know I just left
it like this and it just gave it a
little style put some wood on it Paint
It Black it's nice
all right well this one it's a little
bit easier to see it has a little bit of
a rag top on it okay this one doesn't it
was an option back then and this one had
one so yeah it's kind of cool you could
open it up you could stand up in it you
have a bunch of people in the car one of
them kind of smells a little you open up
your rag top air it out it's beautiful
thing who drives a Volkswagen bus
someone who just likes to smile and have
fun like if you're behind the wheel of
one of these buses and you're like like
you got up you're making faces and you
look like you're mad then life just did
not work out for you and no matter what
you do you're not going to be happy
unless it broke you know broke down and
then you got to push it then you can
make that face but when you're driving
one of these you just it feels good you
pop open the windows in the front the
air hits your face it's just you know
you're smiling it's it it's great it's a
great feeling all right let me show you
a little something here the windows pop
out
foreign
so if you're going about 15 miles an
hour that's that's pretty awesome right
there
people think it's just gonna put putt
but no that'll you'll pass people but
you got to be careful too because you're
very top heavy so you know you got to
remember that it's not made to go that
fast
so the fish tanks got made uh by a
television show called tanked so they
showed up here and they're like hey man
we heard you like Volkswagen buses what
do you think of if we make you a you
know fish tank out of a bus to take a
bus and cut it in half and convert them
into a fish tank like Volkswagen people
saw that and they're like cringing
because these are masterpieces however
the bus that we got came from Brazil and
Brazilian buses are known as
Frankenstein buses because they take
different years and put a bus together
so like they'll use the front end of a
67 and the rear end of a 73 and just put
them together and so those buses were
not as valuable as the other ones and so
we were able to get one really really
cheap they chopped it and that's what
you see right there
[Music]
this started off as just like it's cool
to have one or two but then I was
obsessed with filling the space and then
putting up all the artwork on the walls
and then just making it look cool and at
one point I go I got a little Museum
here and then I actually painted on the
wall that it's a museum the mural in the
background is uh the Wolfsburg plant in
Wolfsburg Germany but that was the
original one right there and I had the
pleasure of visiting uh that plant which
is still there looks just like that the
idea for the travel posters uh basically
it's a lot of the places that I've
performed clearly I haven't driven the
buses there but since it's a museum and
I'm trying to make it part of a thing
each one is a different place that I've
performed or I plan on performing so
like for example I've done shows in in
Dubai Kuala Lumpur Montreal I've been in
Paris Oslo Norway Mexico haven't been to
Marine Colombia but I'm working on it
Pablo Escobar is in the back of that
truck I you know I was having a little
fun I was bored so I told the artist if
they could put Pablo Escobar in the back
of the uh the truck because they were
always sneaking them around back in the
day got some special
special cargo yeah
glad you noticed this collection alone
has drawn people from all over the world
to come down to want to see it document
it and take pictures and just you know
talk about it and and feature it I've
managed to make my own little Mexican
Graceland here between the Volkswagens
and all my memorabilia so it's it's
pretty cool
[Music]